those out of that I didn't have time to
power up there I got as far as this
that's it I got to open it okay quick
rundown let's the twenty till kickoff
cube fanatics we've been here before 123
players war zone raided 1761 average
rating time handicap 30-minute
tournament
anybody could enter no level experience
required times will be adjusted
according to rating in order to help
balance things out hopefully my new
mousepad is gonna be treating me well
let's go oh no now one of these no way
it better give me an hair if anything
this happened before the last time I
played this was a two days ago when I
played here we go c5 for the win
quick resign if you don't know I'm gonna
be um I'm going to be throwing out
oh that Queens gonna get killed isn't
she Oh
let's go night before oh the bishops
dead there's a fork ensuing four ensuing
fork Forks everywhere Knights cooked hit
the Queen grab the F pun or the ape on
let's go here it's check let's come back
and now I will run a pond for the for a
touchdown break down the dark squares
between your opponent my opponent
doesn't have dark squares is the Queen
dead she's dead
she's a dead Queen dead Queen I want to
get to b2 b2 is the plan here cooked
Queen she's cooked I have the knight
next I want to stay here I want to get
on the diagonal wow that's me that's a
quick kill back to tournament two a
bunch of two's here we go here we go so
far so good
efore and
I'm still getting used to the speed of
this mouse pad I'm liking it so far and
actually um go quicker
f5 get ready Bishop h6 let's break it
open
Bishop h6 let's do Bishop h6 right now
night after night h5 take my knight he's
free he actually he wasn't free it was
very costly
that night was been very costly uh-oh
big trouble big trouble
pieces are falling chop on f7 coming up
a big chop a ruski okay
coming up the Knights hit the bishops
hit the rooks hit the pawns hit
everything said pins everywhere chase
away the night f7 is crumbling this has
to be good mate threat double checkmate
take the Queen
it's double checkmate take here with the
check and then look for mates where's
the main where is the tricky mate my
knight let's just go here where's the
mate oh just back my bishop up and play
my knight wants to be on f7 I can also
take this bishop oh ok back up and now
Knight here is it brutal isn't it this
is this is mate really really soon isn't
it I got the Queen I probably missed a
bunch of mates okay they resigned or did
they they forfeit no time I don't know
one of the other eight seven six six
alright
more c5 now what 26 minutes and change a
lot of time left we are Oh what do we
have here who's in first quick resigner
good 9 e4 Oh another quick resigner
what's happening here 13 uh-oh fear in
the new mouse pad are people feeling
new mousepad okay be very scared of the
new mousepad 96 he's having fun he's
playing in new territory
know what I'm saying like g4
these are always funny to look back on
because I I surprise myself
anyhow Bishop you want to play don't you
no no no no I want to come over here
pawn push leading to a fork or not or
not grab this guy he's free he's been
free take the free stuff come back home
let's go bishop do something okay watch
over this square I actually don't even
on all the night they're pin I'm on the
pond as well pin it's gonna be unpinned
okay I want to get rid of the dark
square Bishop and then give me let's go
Bishop mate Queen f2 as a follow up
Queen f2 you know you want to do it or
not King right here I know it's not a
mouse slip I do I didn't want a castle
oh okay 27 ticks left
okay b3 coming under heavy fire real
soon right now real soon right now can
you grab that pond
double up double trouble doubled rooks
double trouble here we go capturing with
Czech open this up open this up right
now
here we go open it up and then break it
down check check check everywhere kill
the Queen the Queen stead that's me very
close to it very soon incoming mate and
a couple four back to tournament they
resigned 23 12 12-8 8 8 8 7 Jonathan II
for for the win Fischer no it's not
Fischer it's win a war it's a win a war
French where did that come from
ok Bishop g2 it stops any excitement on
the other bishops dead
Bishop no snow excitement on the G file
now I'm gonna do this I want the F file
open it up here it's a little scary
hit that clean all the bishops gonna
move I'm on the Queen I got the bishop
with the check I should have done that
first maybe how they resigned back to
term in 35 20 23 tix 23 tix 23 minutes
and change okay
Morsi 5 grab the deeper a 6 I gotta
watch out for pre moving that there
might be like a sneaky Bishop g5 move
stay on this diagonal you know what I'm
setting up more fishing go fish is the
name of the game
Go Fish Go Fish Go Fish h2 back the
tournament 49 2015 23 minutes and change
tick tick tick tick tick
efore for for the win efore for white c5
for black most of the time what do we
got
let's go Oh time ticker that's okay
that's all right I do homework I use my
time wisely I don't wanna do homework
I'm gonna use my time let's see this guy
right oh oh oh oh we're back in action
here we're back to live we see movement
here movement on the scene support e5
might go fishing again more fishing more
fishing take the night dark squares kill
the night fishing poles pin now dark
square weaknesses okay Bishop f6 is it
lethal lethal isn't it
take my night make a decision Bishop you
got to make a decision okay
no no no no new castle g4 I'm gonna take
that night out I'm not gonna deal with
that night
no let me take this as well my knight
wants to be on f6 he's more excited
about being on f6 than any other piece
actually I'm looking for mates real soon
mate time on f8 f 8 May
maybe I should defend it with my queen
first okay this is bad
tough situation for Team black that's me
back to tournament 65 what are the
leaders let me go to it 65 36 22 21
minutes Karpov chess what do we have oh
they have negative 16 where they just
resigning the games
what's going on let's go here one minute
less than a minute another non mover ah
man okay homework time cook home cooking
my tab will end up blinking if somebody
has moved so let's see who's on my heels
who's on my heels uh uh uh uh what did I
get did I get points did I at least get
points for that
I don't know what just happened
hopefully I got points for that I wasn't
able to see castle Queenie one Queen
here an accelerated version oh I should
have played d3 my bishops is dead man no
he's not
b5 not could go back without c4 killing
him let's do it anyhow right now
f5 f7 is very weak hit it
f7 old rook takes coming up the Knights
gonna move and then my rook is hit um I
guess that's alright I just come I come
back here I want to get to d5 Knight
right here might be annoying Queen here
I guess I have to work myself into a pin
let's go here
no yes okay that's all right I'm on the
rope f7 is hit three times now okay I'm
on the Queen and the rook this is I'm up
a full piece there's no pawn push so I
got this and then come back we're gonna
have resigned time might be resigned
time pawns pinned Bishop here and then
that's gonna be lights out or actually
let me take the knight and then play
here that it's an unavoidable mate not
really the Queen would have g4 to defend
Bishop here then I take and then Bishop
f6 leads to me or just this this is
leading to matin one can't be avoided or
yes a good pawn push I lied I lied sorry
about that one Queen h6 to g7 making two
threat what's the plan no time back to
chairman
9450 47 18 minutes and change oh man
I got a watch I got a look behind my
shoulder ok Blumenfeld we're not let me
just do this alright let's let's close
this up right here my bishop I'm gonna
block like that and now let's see the
bishop is gonna have to take otherwise I
get b5 in all right and I should dump b5
I had the chance for b5 ok now I have it
again it's available and now this pond
is a problem actually I want to get my
Bishop on b5 I'm looking for a great
home the knight is pinned I'll pin
tonight I'm vacating the square for my
bishop and things are very uncomfortable
for this Knight he's dead he's a dead
man back to term at they resigned 114 75
52 18 minutes and change okay what do we
have double up double those points and
what's going on less than a minute for
black why aren't they moving they have 8
points right now in the tournament
Premal more home cook more cooking oh
he's right on my heels oh oh let's do
this oh man I'm getting caught from
behind winnow are take my knight okay
where are my darks for a bishop on B
what does he want to be my parents to be
on h6 dark square weaknesses dark square
weaknesses my bishops gonna have a lot
of fun isn't he this guy this bishop the
dark square traveler the darks great
traveler hit the rook there's no
castling hit the Queen b7 is going down
isn't it
guard this pawn abandoned this guy and
maybe trap to clean this is um I don't
want to trade Queens dark squares
pawn push just open this up and get to
d8 no no no no I want to do pawn push
soon really really really soon no I
don't want to Queen trade stop that
I don't want to Queen trade stop that ah
stop trying to tre clean watch a cleans
let's get away from me no no get away
no Queen trade no no no I don't worry
that's make a one watch out dark squares
very difficult to defend uh-oh
dark squares is back on tough tough
story right here my queen is weaseling
in she's a weasel err back to terment
they forfeit n time 134 115 uh-oh but
here we go
what are we gonna have I'm getting
caught from behind here I have 12 games
in I think oh wow it's a good thing I
had my palm there
Queenie two is needed tempo gainers
coming up tempo gainer or not I'm just
up a piece runaway night
what's this Knight doing Oh Oh my
opponents gonna get pushed around now
Knight here I win it he's cooked cooked
night on a four I got this pawn queen
here I guess is best Queen check oh
they're getting silly silly time
okay back to tournament 154 115 I think
second place guys is ready to win oh
this guy has given me beatings before
let's go no beatings this time night
here Bishop where no I don't want to get
kicked away actually let's do this I'm
gonna take the knight or am i I lied I
lied on that one I gotta get rid of that
light square bishop you need to get out
of here oh wait a second I'm gonna take
that pawn and then hit f7 hopefully this
works
oh I should just take in the rook I
thought I was gonna be in a pen
Oh Oh okay now I'm gonna do this hit the
Queen for Kurowski no not so fast not so
fast my Knights gonna get flushed away
oh I should have done that move earlier
pawn push take this Knight let's Castle
looks weird I'm gonna drop that pond but
so what ah I want to get back to f5 can
we have that happen please a file
opening up
let's go Knight um come on
why aren't these okay here we go look
right here
rook here scary time No
oh it's scary it's very scary g2 oh no
it's very scary
home it's time I don't have any time I
should take in the pond while I had the
chance I can't go there there'd be big
trouble oh man
I'm in trouble I'm getting made it I'm
getting made it I'm getting mated oh
it's me uh and me oh they had me they
had me they probably still have me Oh
Queen takes pawn would have been me I'm
dead anyhow somehow oh I have nothing
how much time do I have is this
defendable is this working somehow
please say it works does this work no
way
just working I don't know I only have
two minutes no two seconds oh I have to
dodge a million checks
I can't dodge a million checks can i oh
that guy did it again he's too fast too
fast and I'm too slow ah man I actually
well they had me I was lucky to even get
their back to tournament quick resigner
what a rebound don't count me out oh
this guy again he's gonna give me a
beating didn't he have enough didn't
he'd give me enough of beating how can I
make an improvement Oh was that a mouse
slip did they do a most slipper right
there light square bishop so I don't
have to worry about pins this time
that's a relief that is Oh light square
weak
is come on that can't be good come on
light squares for the win F pawn push
take this guy open this up over here
there we go oh I should just played f5
let's do it right now
oh that king is dead it's got to be dead
right here we go
safety first oh they have play against
my my jeep on again look at all this
pressure what I do deserve this okay
everything's cozy now there's still pawn
push let's go my queen wants to see come
on Queen you can see now give me the B
file
let's go Knight um right here clean
check and stuff Oh check okay I'm gonna
go for this and now I'm on that pawn on
f7 come on you can do it what am i doing
okay wait this is good this is good I
get that aged 87 pawn pin and then a win
no I don't have it
ah check why can't it just be simple I
don't have any time fifteen seconds wait
wait is this a1 king of no I just get a
free piece but how much time do I have
come on
why'd I do that this is bad technique
very bad technique run pawn I need to
run with my pond run run oh I gotta come
over here what a sad story I'm running
the risk of getting mated oh don't get
mated don't get mated what am i doing
what am i doing I'm getting made it and
stuff Oh where's Mike was my king doing
I don't have any time again oh man I'm
dead I don't have anything oh I'm down a
time again don't fear me up with that
guy oh man ten minutes and change
crap let's go ten minutes
those are two big glosses right there
why can't it convert those those are
fantastic positions those are fantastic
positions now now I'm on till now I'm on
till bullet Ches I'm tilt right now
let's go let's go I'm ready to rumble
with the a6 move let's go come on I
can't have these uh laggers right here
what's happening six Queen c7 I'm
looking to go fish this could be a quick
win sort of man those are two losses how
am I still in first it's probably
because of the quick resign errs and pre
move that or not there might be a sneaky
Bishop move one day oh yeah I'll get
caught off guard and I'll scream when it
happens what's the count
170 153 man it's too close it just can't
be easy cannon 19 minutes actually 10
seconds less than 10 this is nothing's
gonna happen here
it better be my opponents clock that's
moving this whole time we're gonna see
very soon game over
yes back determinant 190 173 oh I gotta
keep winning oh this is a big game this
is a big game be prepared this is the
second place guy what are we gonna have
Oh what are we gonna have here let's do
this is it working
is this working what's happening here
Oh for Kurowski or I get the Queen did I
get the Queen no I'm not getting the
Queen why'd I do that I'm not getting
the Queen what's happening here
run King sneaky moves look for the
sneaky moves look up and over root 2 B 3
I have a time advantage no let's not
allow that
I got a do um okay this is actually what
let's come over here
and defend what okay I gotta go over
here after crawl into a little ball here
get out of there Queen you have no
business being there let's trade let's
get this up maybe I got to defend this
and Queen trade what's the material cod
I'm actually down material why would I
want to try it what I've tried why would
I want to trade if I'm down material
somebody tell me that oh I'm getting
this pawn where am I now they're
defending what am I'm floundering with
my king
what's this move doing what is my King
doing come over here I got a defend uh
ugly here where's my butt what's my
bishop doing want to play here any move
I'm dropping that I'm dropping upon and
now what oh this is scary
and let me take this and give check oh
wait they missed that and I need to get
this pawn right here here how much time
okay I got this right seven seconds just
break this open mates yes that's a
clutch win that's a clutch win it's
about time oh that was a big win right
there that was a big win that could be
the decider was that the decider I
wasn't expecting that because I lost two
games earlier oh that's a big one that
could be the the clincher the playoff
winner
there will be no playoff okay let's go
Queen do some damage don't give up on
the fishing pole idea I'm hanging on
that pond now I have five f5 Queen c7
G foul play queenside castle get out of
there Queen Queen c7 or b8 she might
have to go to b8
it's got to be eight oh I kind of landed
a fork that's okay
let's come here at queenside castle
greenside castle let's do this night
takes pilots that can't be good right oh
there's like a fork here or a pin you
know what I meant
pin I should have done that followed up
with E 5 it's happening right now
'if i after the night blocks he's dead
dead night cook tonight no recovering
dead night and I'm gonna hit the Queen
after the e-file opens up resignation
time five minutes and change oh five
minutes and change let's go
hitting the Queen in-betweener
look out for the in-between errs oh just
anything why do you take so long why did
you just take so long right there okay
why did I just give that piece up Oh
give a check even if it's wrong okay no
no I got this no doubt right no doubt no
doubt
right here right cuz I have a time edge
finally I need that time edge back
determined to 3201 don't you dare try to
sneak up on me are we gonna get paired
up again I might have to uh win again
that was an ugly game by the way that I
won that was ugly that was not um
something to mimic don't Tom dropping
stuff this is another one bad news
pin a knight Bishop takes maybe get to
f6 okay I could take that and then pile
up I'm the knight oh what's happening
here oh my Queens getting hit let's keep
the pin and then hit it again hit again
unavoidable Knight has to go there okay
now we're having a bunch of trades
Queens are off and the bishops ready I'm
hitting the night actually Oh what's
happening here Thai burners are these
time burners that might be time burners
upon push no no no just take the pun
looking for mate we're made on the back
rank my knight wants to play he's not
doing anything
paan push a couple times keep that net
or yeah I keep that mating net available
actually rook right here is the way to
go isn't it there's night check if the
King defends now there's two different
rooks that could go to the back rank
maybe if this Knight moves it's me this
is made over here
actually both rooks can go there after
the night block forced back to
tournament two 52:21 let's go three
minutes and change don't you dare try to
catch up if I get this one right here I
think I have it let's go if I just get
this one I think everything is gonna be
nice and cozy I might have to do d5
right now yes and get my knight out get
my bishop out get castled that Bishop is
gonna kill me oh they're ready to launch
other h7 no just do it right now just to
stop any silly stuff you know silly
stuff please I don't want to deal with
any of the silly stuff hit that Bishop
and get my light square Bishop out here
I guess it's a good spot my knight wants
to actually go here I was gonna go back
to c6 but this is material land okay two
minutes and change I should be getting
this when are we gonna have a resign I
get a free rook I'm on the bishop now
can I get in one more game maybe maybe
after this could I win this one quicker
then I'm real quick hopefully Queen
trade okay stop that Knight from doing
anything oh they didn't take my coin oh
oh they're giving me this they giving me
that one of these two
if it goes to g1 I go here if it goes
anywhere else I go to H one time burner
one minutes 25 seconds come on let's go
let's go let's go can I get one more -
72 41 1 minute 23 22 21 actually 1
minute 18
vexy m oh he has a negative 103 he's a
quick resigner guy isn't he is he a
quick resigner does he resign quick come
on f7 f7 I still want to get to f7 so
take care
f7 still on check looking for me real
soon I got the Queen resign 52 I can get
the rook looking for mates real soon
mate sneaky move is this a main idea or
something well it's not I'm just in a
pen how much time 35 seconds wait
where's the main I don't know I didn't
really have a mate going in the other
direction did I oh if they don't read oh
no no no okay I can't win this one I
better win the tournament though I'm
dropping everything what's happening
here come on 14 seconds what did I get
what did I get what did I get don't tell
me second no are you kidding me ah
second place confetti what somebody
resigned back-to-back oh you kidding me
oh man good games all right at the last
second Oh apparently there was a
buzzer-beater ah so close yeah
a couple speed bumps I got lucky even to
get where I got right there to get where
I got